you
I've talked a lot about Prince of Egypt
before on this - a critic both on the
top 11 underrated nostalgic classics and
the old versus new of Prince Vijay vs.
10 commandments so I'll try to keep this
relatively short and try to say stuff I
haven't said before the story I think is
a safe bet you probably know the Pharaoh
has decided that the slaves have grown
too large in size so he sends his
soldiers to perform mass genocide but
one family wants their baby to live puts
him in a basket and sends him floating
down the river where oddly enough the
basket comes across the Queen and
decides to adopt the baby and call him
Moses years later Moses grows up and
realizes his true heritage disgraced by
who he is he leaves his brother and
family behind and finds a life of peace
far away but that doesn't last for long
as God Himself comes down and tells
Moses that he is to be the deliverer of
the Jews Moses returns fighting his
brother is now Pharaoh and the epic
battle begins between Pharaoh and Moses
over what will happen to the Jewish
people the film is gorgeous this is one
of the best looking animated films I've
ever seen
I'm not really a big fan of Egypt or the
desert but by God the shots and the
angles they get in it it's just
unbelievable so much attention is being
drawn to how to tell this story
faithfully but not exactly the same as
the ten commandments and it does exactly
that it has its own unique style as own
unique look even the characters are
different the relationship between the
brothers seems genuine they both now
have grown up and they both now have new
responsibilities that they wish to honor
and do not want to break but at the same
time there's still family and this is
what makes great drama does Val Kilmer
as Moses and Ray finds as ramasees and
both of them are fantastic even the
other celebrity voices low distracting
at times like Jeff Goldblum Patrick
Stewart still match well to the
character and tone that the movie is
trying to get across it's just
distracting and that you can tell it's
their voices but you'll warm up to him
pretty quick something else I've never
talked about is the muse
the music is also wonderful I think the
theme they have for the burning bush is
one of the most comforting nicest themes
I've ever heard it's just a great sound
and creates this wonderful mood
now some people can't and have been
turned off by this movie because well
while Ten Commandments was just intended
for adults this is more older children
and adults that is to say there are
songs there is some comedy relief and
there are some weirdly drawn characters
and yes that can be distracting at times
like half the time there's no segue into
the song Steve Martin and Martin Short
as the high priests are a little odd and
out of place at times and horrible to
say but because it is sort of a Disney
style maybe it could have benefited more
from a little bit more the Disney design
I mean some of them look good that
others do look kind of odd but with that
said the distracting moments are never
too distracting and you know what I like
the songs I think they help move along
the story and they do in a very visually
a musically interesting way so I don't
mind them I think they really work but
many would argue if you're really gonna
tell the story of Moses and you want to
step up your animation company and make
it more adult you should probably leave
some of the stuff behind I'd be lying if
I said I didn't feel that was totally
true especially with something as heavy
as the story of Moses but I also
understand the need to appeal to a
general public and like I said I think
they work it in pretty well so I stand
by it
well at least by the songs I do feel bad
this movie is not more appreciated and
maybe it is because Ten Commandments was
just such a landmark and even though
this is a good film yeah it's probably
not really a landmark in any way at
least not the way that most people view
cinematic landmarks but I still think
it's a good strong film better than 10
commandments in fact it has great
characters it has a timeless story it
has wonderful music that has
breathtaking animation with some
breathtaking visuals even if you're one
of those people that can't fully get
into it I still say check it out because
there is some really great stuff in it
and I think the story of Moses deserves
to be told from a different point of
view and this is a very smart point of
view what else can I say I love it
I've seen it a million times before and
I'll definitely see it a million times
again